first time ever met this man was at a
charity golf tournament he's playing
barefoot God who I love this guy he's
Jim McMahon here on the Rich Eisen show
how are you Jim very rich hey Don I'm
doing just fine
so the Mitchell true Biscay hoopla in
Chicago is off the charts after just one
preseason game it does that distance
show you how starving the Bears fan base
is for a W Jim well I'm sure it is and I
didn't see I didn't see what happened
last night I just saw a little quip you
sent me I've never seen the kid play but
it looks like he's got skills it looks
like you move around the pocket looks
like you know it gets rid of the ball
quickly and makes quick decisions and I
might have a bright future you never
know well I think there's I was joking
that there was a parade set up in
Michigan Avenue and Urlacher said I'm
going to be the marshal
it's basically what he said well I know
the feds are hungry for a winner there
that it's been quite a while so
hopefully it will have success yeah I
know I mean and you were you were there
just as you know Jordan was beginning to
ascend and so a lot of people always
think of Chicago as a basketball town
because of Jordan but I would
essentially think you would know
differently correct know Chicago's a
bear town I think it'd always be a bear
town I mean they enjoyed the Jordan
years and the championships and you know
they've always been a cub town in the
Blackhawk down to but I think the Bears
are pretty much the favorite well what
was it like with a parade and watching
Bears fan celebrate Jim well
unforgettable that year right from New
Orleans okay but I did be able to see
all the pictures in the in the news
coverage it was it was unbelievable all
the guys that did go back for the parade
so it was something up but no I'll never
forget no kid now so you went to the Pro
Bowl right after right after that Super
Bowl win correct yeah we left that next
day we didn't go back to the back to
Chicago I didn't even know that in terms
of you know of being a successful
quarterback in Chicago what what what
requires you to have what make up for
choir
you to be successful in that city in
that position something that true Biscay
might have to acquire or have within him
but well it's the same in any city you
don't have five guys up front knowing
what they're doing that it doesn't
matter who your quarterback is so you've
got to get you've got to have a good
offensive line to begin with and then
you can if you have any talent you'll be
able to show it from there hmm I'm a
couple of questions for you for your
championship years Jim I've always
wanted this and you know sweetness would
have been 63 last month what was the
moment like when the fridge scored that
touchdown in the Super Bowl and not him
was he was he upset about it did he ever
say anything about that Jim you know I
get that asked a lot and you know Walter
never said a word to me about it I
didn't know how upset he was or even was
upset you know the game was was such a
lopsided game and and new English
focused that whole game was to stop
Walter Payton and they did a good job of
that I mean it would have been tough for
him to get in because they were so keyed
up on him that's why I think everybody
else was so successful but it's just uh
so people would just assume he was not
pleased about scoring a touchdown you
never said a word to you I don't know it
didn't he never never said a word to me
and we all thought we'd have plenty more
chances you know we got taken out
I think midway through the third quarter
all the starters so you know we thought
we'd have a few more chances to get down
there and score so you know that really
wasn't on anybody's mind I don't think
Super Bowl champion Jim McMahon here on
the Rich Eisen show buddy Ryan passed
away in recent days last year what are
your thoughts on his passing Jim now
that I have you on the phone well it was
it was tough to deal with you know yeah
everybody's going to go through it but
you know buddy was very well loved and
in Chicago especially by his defensive
players and everywhere he coached
I mean his defense will of them and I
was one of the fewer fortunate guys that
he kind of took a liking to in Chicago
and I played for him in Philadelphia and
also in Phoenix so I have a lot of
respect for Buddy Ryan
McMahon here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you feeling these days oh no some
some days better than others I was back
in New York back in June to get another
adjustment so that should hold up for
another month or two I'm hoping you know
they're not my body's just you know
that's why I live in Phoenix that dry
heat feels much better on the body than
anywhere else I found what do you mean
by an adjustment if you don't mind me
asking I I go back every three months to
get this it's called the vi gap
treatment it's called the image-guided
Atlas treatment it's a machine that
sends a vibrating pulse through my neck
and it moves the the bones are out of
whack it moves them enough to let the
spinal fluid flow properly anyway I know
when I start having headaches and sharp
pains in my head it's time to go back to
see the doc no kidding and animate
anything you do feel the difference it
does make you feel better
oh there's no doubt about it I mean it
you know it allows the the spinal fluid
to flow properly when it's not that's
what's causing all the pain in my head
that's what cause of CTE community each
way at the bone it could certainly eat
away at the brain and that's unless
y-you know you're seeing this in all
these guys that have had their brains
look up right and did you see that study
recently where we're a hundred and ten
out of a hundred and eleven brains that
were studied did have CTE did you see
that yeah what is what you think about
that I'm not surprised by it you know
it's uh this games been going on a long
time and a lot of these guys been
misdiagnosed for years and and it's
unfortunate but you know that's the way
the game is I mean I think a lot of guys
that they were if they were smart they'd
go get their own MRIs and take a look at
their heads in their necks to see if if
things are in the right place as if
they're not they're going to have
problems down the line do you have any
regrets playing Jim I regret playing
when I was hurt I mean it was especially
in 1986 when my shoulder was gone I had
no labrum at all in the front of my
shoulder they kept telling there was
nothing wrong with it
you know so they shot it up and I played
with ten more games and I finally went
to see a real doctor and Frank Jobe out
in LA and he said within five minutes
your shoulders coming out of the socket
and tell these guys that all here so I
got it fake so I was I was lucky to be
able to come back and play after that it
could have been really really bad yeah I
mean jeez you played all the way to 1996
you spent a couple of years in
Philadelphia and there's a question I've
always wanted to ask you too about this
gym because uh you know I heard this
story I heard the story from Seth's
jointer that is it true that one day in
the vet you were warming up and got
hungry and in full uniform hopped off
the field and went to the concourse and
got a pizza and brought it back to a
field is that a true story Jim McMahon
well that was pretty good pregame where
we were out there in pregame I was I
think it was a cup in Atlanta okay I
remember getting a piece up in Atlanta I
was standing in line with everybody else
just had my my football pants on and you
know a half shirt mm-hmm
I had a ball that was that was going to
be my payment from when I got to the but
I got to the front of the line I said
hey uh you know I'm playing down there
today I said I'd I have my wallet but
I'll trade you this ball for a pizza
and she said I can't do that I said go
get the manager and he came out and he
goes he won't give me that ball for PC
he goes give him two pizzas I got two
pies and went down a set of the
goalposts and ate him right before the
game and did you share it with any of
your teammates
I asked anybody that wanted a they were
they weren't too hungry okay
it did coach I'd say anything is he
giving with it no my he yell with me a
few times I ordered hot dogs down there
some sausages you know ever gotten great
order some food those games those games
last a long time you know so it is a
true story that's what I heard that you
had actually done that then and they
asked you for money and you're like hey
I've got no I've got no pockets here
here's a football yeah yeah the manager
was happy to take a ball I bet so so you
get in fact off the football then oh
yeah okay fantastic
hey Jim it's always great chatting with
you I'd love to keep in touch and have
you back on as much as you're as much as
you're willing just to chat with you
Barry
any time well if you got it thank you
Jim that's Jim McMahon Super Bowl
champion Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon Eastern hungry
stations across the country and audience
if you like some of that get some more
of that on the Rich Eisen show lap
follow all the information you see right
here on the Rich Eisen show